north korea resumed a series of
ballistic missile launches overnight
conducting its fourth test of the new
year south korea's military says two
missiles were fired from an airport in
north korea's capital they flew toward
japan then apparently landed in the
ocean japan's government called the
launch a threat to peace and security
elizabeth palmer is in thailand
monitoring north korea's latest
challenge to the u.s liz good morning
good morning
today's missile test is all part and
parcel of north korea's determination
openly stated to develop better and more
powerful missiles
already this month watched by the leader
kim jong-un it claims to have tested two
hypersonic models that can be maneuvered
in the air
also a pair of short arranged versions
including one designed to be fired from
a train
that was likely retaliation for new
sanctions imposed by the u.s on five
north koreans involved in the missile
program
[Music]
state media released video on its
youtube channel with grandiose
soundtrack of missiles moving on january
14th toward the launch site this is to
some extent spectacle but the tests are
also practical exercises for the north
korean military to fine-tune its growing
arsenal
and with no arms control negotiations
with the u.s on the horizon to move
toward developing long-range missiles
and crucially nuclear warheads gail
all right elizabeth thank you very much